you do the distance in three dimensions
you're doing the same thing you're
taking the difference in the X is
squaring you're taking the difference in
the Y's squaring and you're also taking
the difference in the Z coordinates
squaring you add all quantities together
and take the square root that gives you
the distance in 3d right now the
midpoint formula it's more like an
average you're adding the x-coordinates
together and dividing by two you're
adding the y-coordinates dividing by two
and three dimensions you're also going
to be adding the z coordinates and
dividing by two and that's going to give
you the midpoint of that line segment in
space or in 3d so let's go to example
number one so here you can see they're
giving us five three negative two and
you can think of this as x1 comma y1
comma Z ones ok so just in alphabetical
order and then this is like x2 y2 z2 the
true just means point number two now the
Z I put a little line through it just to
differentiate it from the number two
because sometimes a Z does look like two
right so let's do the distance formula
first so a distance what do we do well
what we have to do is we have to
subtract the axis so I'm going to do 2
minus 5 quantity squared plus negative 1
minus 3 the quantity squared plus 3
minus negative 2 the quantity squared
now be careful with those negatives 2
minus 5 is negative 3 negative 3 squared
is 9 negative 1 minus 3 is negative 4
negative 4 squared is positive 16 3
minus negative 2 is really like adding a
positive that's 5 squared which is 25 if
we add those together what do we get it
comes out to let's see that's 41 plus 9
is 50 so the square root of 50 well we
can simplify that into 25 times 2 or 5
square root of 2 that would be an exact
answer for the distance okay now for the
midpoint same kind of idea what we're
going to do is we're going to just like
get two dimensions we're going to add
the X's together and divide by two Y's
and Z's the same way so let's go ahead
and do that so we've got five plus two
divided by two we've got negative 1 plus
3 divided by 2 and we've got 3 plus
negative 2 divided by 2 so if we
simplify this comes out to 7 over 2 this
comes out to 2 over 2 which is 1 and
this comes out to 1 over 2 which is 1/2
and that's going to be the
the middle or